talk about something today Okajima was
talking yeah Pete's boy no I was at
tokyo game show he was talking to a few
different like I think it's just a press
conference panel yeah and he had gone
into some light details as he has want
to do about death stranding the new
Norman Reedus the game that we've seen
that such a weird the Norman Reedus game
o death stranding that's why you were
just making fun of my phrasing but it
was a weird trailer that we first saw
around III at the sony press conference
last year to say the least weird e the
lease weird to say the trick you missed
a comma in there i think sure oh yeah
very least it was Lee yeah it was weird
uh yeah so I guess we want to go into
the light details that he did mention
but also kind of just conjecture
speculate maybe what we want out of it
conjecture 8 yes Spectre so he the
weirdest thing he said was it would be
out before the 2020 olympics in tokyo
but then he clarified saying well
actually i'll take that further it'll be
out before the year that Akira was said
which is 2019 right suggesting a 2018
release they just say it what if what if
it's almost ready and he meant like
December of this year I don't think
that's it I know sure but that'd be
that'd be crazy so this is just Kojima
being Kojima and kind of making a kind
of so might be myself I mean yeah not
many other people but as he actually
like serious about this or here's the
thing with the independent student I
without Konami breathing down his neck
do you think like he even cares when it
releases now I think he cares I mean
like to some degree his reputation is on
the line here yeah so like what do you
like what do you think about the fact
that do you think that he has more
creative freedom like in this like funny
he's heading up his own studio but i
don't know i'm curious if that'll be a
boon to him in the long run or if
that'll be like too much freedom where's
i think i know what you're getting all
right like will he be someone hinge that
like yeah undecipherable yeah no I don't
think that I mean there's going to be
some weird narrative stuff and he's you
know he always tries to inject this sort
of like misdirection or keeps things
really vague until the last moment I
think that's going to continue I don't
know it's going to be
you be like mmm more than it was with
metal geared towards the end he and you
look at that series as a whole he went
to some pretty great lengths to make
some pretty ridiculous stuff yeah i
think is I think we're gonna see the
same level of strangeness I don't think
I don't know the kink and I'm sure
anyone can go farther than they have
before but I can't even imagine how in
this case there's also some hyperbole
about being like an online component
that's unlike anything you've played
before right just sounds more like a
Okajima it does and like you know it's
like okay take it at face value that
would be great if he could somehow
reinvent what online you know
multiplayer / co-op gaming is but that's
such a hard thing to conceive like how
would you do that and the way he
describes it is like okay online games
people would fight it re okay
traditional gaming people would fight an
MPC with weapons then people were
fighting each other then they were
fighting alongside one another he's like
kind of tiptoeing around co-op but
saying that people are going to be
connected to one another somehow but not
in the same way same umbilical cord
judging by the trail yeah right I don't
know like it'sit's weird so what does
that mean like in your world when you
walk this direction it pulls me back and
so we're constantly struggling to move a
literal connection yeah like that would
be super [ __ ] weird like I don't know
that a platformer where you can't go too
far screamer micromachines where if you
did bush the lock screen they blew up
Jeff play that No Oh Micro Machines 1964
is a hidden gem if you will Kojima also
said that it may feature a female hero
protagonist I think with his words were
you the one saying maybe Norn Reyes
isn't even the lead character yeah I
think that'd be cool if he wasn't I mean
like I don't want Norman Reedus to be
the thing that is the focus of the game
yeah it's the I don't know I have this
weird thing where identify actors as
themselves not really as the characters
they play unless they're really good
actors mm-hmm so if Norman Reedus was a
star of this I would just be staring at
Norman Reedus the whole time and it hmm
kind of strange about that as we all
would yeah well his butt looks great
let's be honest he was completely naked
except for the baby attached to him that
trailer was weird you guys have any
speculation as to what it might have
meant we talk about this back on the
lobby stage show but i don't know i saw
theories that those five things in the
sky we're like Metal Gear Solid
one two three four five yeah baby baby
is Metal Gear Solid attached to me know
yeah I think we should give anyone more
credit than being that obvious with
their references like if we're able to
guess that just by looking at it like
I'm pretty sure that's probably like
misdirection on his part yeah let's be
honest I guess so it can't be that
obvious so that but the strands are
connected to people right yeah the large
multiple strands my my suspicion is like
with those four or five figures like
being like God's creeping in we
connected to them and then they're
pulling us like maybe each strand is
like a sin or like a problem you have
Rogers puppets well downloads yeah by
our penance he did focus a little bit on
the idea of death stranding but also
live stranding like what it means in
real life right like dolphins will
sometimes beach themselves when they do
so and they're alive in the process
that's live streaming and the opposite
of debts training how to read into that
I can't even begin to imagine but death
strandings when like a dead whale washes
up on shore is that what you're saying
that's almost what I'm saying okay but
I'm saying that there are two types of
stranding there's a long and he made a
point to differentiate between the two
okay so I'm trying to imagine how that
feeds into the actual like discussion of
the game maybe that's just in reference
to wasn't Moby Dick studios at first
before the reveal of five maybe he's
still just chasing the well he's never
gonna catch a god yeah don't put it by
Kojima he could be like literary like
that I he likes action movies but he's
no dolt you know he's doing love yeah
ever since you said it to me all right
any other speculation about what's going
on with this game female protagonists is
all like he doesn't have the best
history with female characters I mean he
has strong female characters but I think
maybe I'm letting the whole quiet
controversy before the game release kind
of I mean taint my opinion quiet
definitely like put of like a real
shitty veneer over his history with
women like it's not always been
spectacular but you look at some
characters like Meryl like you knew she
was pretty strong she was pretty good
we'll see it could be a female that
might just be his way of saying it could
be male or female
you get a pic your gender mm-hmm I mean
didn't know when Ray's have some
c-section scars on his body oh hey this
this guy hi smart man hmm so maybe he's
just gonna use Norman Reedus as a female
lead as a surrogate okay I see what
you're saying you know all right we're
on the same page anyway as for you leave
your craziest speculation in the
comments below and I kind of want to
read those because I have no idea what's
going on with this game